President Trump did not take a holiday
from politics on Thanksgiving Day he
continued his recent complaints about
Congress and judges blocking his
initiatives the president also warned
Mexico he may close the entire southern
border if the Mexican government cannot
control immigrants trying to get into
the u.s. we Jew Jiang is in West Palm
Beach Florida near the president's
mar-a-lago resort reach a good morning
good morning Dana and good morning to
everybody in a televised Thanksgiving
Day conference call with military
leaders around the world president Trump
thanked servicemembers but he also took
time to boast about himself while
criticizing the federal judiciary and
slamming the situation unfolding at the
southern border after they gonna use
lethal force President Trump said
American troops will be allowed to use
lethal force at the southern border
against an approaching group of migrants
I'm not gonna let the military be taken
advantage of a White House official says
the president approved a memo from chief
of staff John Kelly instructing the
Department of Defense to allow use of
force including lethal force where
necessary even though it's illegal for
the military to act as law enforcement
defense secretary James Madison the memo
as a request not an order stressed most
of the nearly 6,000 active-duty soldiers
will be unarmed we find that it's it
gets to a level where we are gonna lose
control or our people are going to start
getting hurt we will close entry into
the country for a period of time the
president also warned of a government
shutdown in December if Congress doesn't
approve funding for his proposed border
wall the wall is just a part of border
secure very important but probably the
most important part and while still on
the phone with troops overseas the
president's pep talk took the political
turn we get a lot of bad court decisions
from the Ninth Circuit which has become
a big thorn in our side as he complained
about the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
which issued a temporary restraining
order earlier this week
blocking the Trump administration from
preventing migrants who crossing to the
US illegally from
seeking asylum when they tell you how to
protect your border to disgrace in a
rare statement this week Chief Justice
John Roberts pushed back against the
president's rhetoric on federal judges
John Roberts has been speaking a little
bit about it but President Trump
continued his public feud I like him and
I respect him but I think we have to use
some common sense and President Trump
continued his criticism of the ninth
circuit on Twitter writing security
professionals at the border cannot do
their job because quote judicial
activism and interference from the ninth
circuit he also teased he'd make his
first trip to visit deployed troops
overseas but would not say where or when
Alex we Joe thank you